Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Every day in America, 130 people die from overdosing on opioids, including prescription pain medication, heroin, and synthetic opioids such as fentanyl. That's according to the National Institute on Drug Abuse. It's estimated that nearly 2 million people around the country are grappling with opioid addiction and its devastating families and communities. In the face of these grim statistics, psychologists are offering new solutions to help end the opioid epidemic, including non-pharmaceutical
欢迎收听美国心理学会的双周播客节目《心理学谈话》，我是主持人凯特琳·露娜。根据美国国家药物滥用研究所的数据，在美国，每天有130人死于阿片类药物过量，其中包括处方止痛药、海洛因以及芬太尼等合成阿片类药物。据估计，全国有近200万人正在与阿片类药物成瘾作斗争，这给无数家庭和社区带来了毁灭性的打击。面对这些严峻的数字，心理学家们正在提供新的解决方案来帮助结束阿片类药物流行，其中包括非药物
treatment for pain and other interventions. The opioid crisis is the topic of a special report in the June 2019 issue of the Monitor on Psychology, APA's magazine for members that covers the science and practice of psychology, as well as how psychology influences society at large. You can read the special report at APA.org slash monitor. Our guest for this episode is APA CEO, Dr. Arthur C. Evans, Jr. Dr. Evans has worked previously in the areas of substance use disorders and addiction, and has approached these issues in a variety of ways.
治疗疼痛和其他干预措施。阿片类药物危机是《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）2019年6月号特别报道的主题。《心理学观察》是美国心理学会（APA）面向会员的杂志，内容涵盖心理学的科学与实践，以及心理学如何对整个社会产生影响。您可以在 APA.org 网站的 monitor 专栏阅读这篇特别报道。我们本期的嘉宾是 APA 首席执行官亚瑟·C·埃文斯（Arthur C. Evans, Jr.）博士。埃文斯博士此前曾在物质使用障碍和成瘾领域工作，并以多种方式处理过这些问题。
As a clinician, he's worked directly with individuals providing direct services and case management. He's served as an administrator and program director, where he's overseen treatment programs for people with opioid dependency. He's also worked on studies examining. different types of treatment for substance use disorders and has engaged in many years of policy work focused on substance use addiction and recovery. Most importantly, he's had a family member impacted by substance use problems. Welcome, Dr. Evans. Thank you. I'm very delighted to be here.
作为一名临床医生，他曾直接与个人合作，提供直接服务和个案管理。他曾担任行政人员和项目主任，负责监督针对阿片类药物依赖人群的治疗项目。他还参与了关于物质使用障碍不同治疗方法的纵向研究，并多年从事专注于物质使用成瘾和康复的政策工作。最重要的是，他的家庭成员也曾受到物质使用问题的影响。欢迎您，埃文斯博士。谢谢。我非常高兴来到这里。
The opioid crisis is one of the biggest societal issues the U.S. is dealing with right now. Do you think enough is being done to address it? Actually, I don't think we're doing enough as a nation on this crisis. We have about 130 people dying every day from, from opioid overdoses. And that's just the tip of the iceberg. If you look at the impact on not only the number of people who have a substance use disorder related to opioids, you look at the impact on families, you look at the impact on industry, it is a national emergency.
阿片类药物危机是美国目前正在处理的最大社会问题之一。您认为为解决这一危机所做的工作够吗？事实上，作为一个国家，我认为我们在应对这场危机方面做得还不够。我们每天大约有130人死于阿片类药物过量。而这只是冰山一角。如果你不仅看到与阿片类药物相关的物质使用障碍人数的影响，还要看到对家庭的影响，对工业的影响，这无疑是一场国家紧急事件。
And I think we have to really not only have a clear national strategy, but we really need to have more resources devoted to this issue. And you've said that APA and its members can be a force for reframing the opioid crisis. What's your vision for how APA can help? Well, absolutely. I, you know, I worked in the substance use field for many years prior to coming to APA. So I worked as an administrator and as a clinician and as a policymaker. And in all of those roles, it becomes very clear that we have to have a different conceptual
我认为我们不仅必须制定清晰的国家战略，还需要为这个问题投入更多资源。您曾说过，APA及其会员可以成为重塑阿片类药物危机的一支力量。对于APA如何提供帮助，您有什么愿景？当然。你知道的，在来到APA之前，我在物质使用领域工作了很多年。所以我曾担任行政人员、临床医生和决策者。在所有这些角色中，变得非常清晰的一点是，我们必须对如何看待阿片类药物成瘾以及如何应对它有不同的
of how we think about opioid addiction and how we approach it. And what I mean by that is this is a condition that affects not only people from a physical standpoint and even a mental standpoint, but it affects families. It affects communities. It affects so many aspects of people's lives. And what happens too often is that the solutions to substance use disorders are often focus almost solely on treatment. And one of the things that I know from my experience, and I think the research also supports, is the idea that there are many other aspects, for example,
概念。我的意思是，这种情况不仅从身体甚至心理角度影响着人们，还会影响家庭。它影响社区。它影响人们生活的方方面面。而往往发生的情况是，物质使用障碍的解决方案通常几乎只专注于治疗。根据我的经验，我知道的一点是，而且我认为研究也支持这一观点，即还有许多其他方面，例如
housing. There are issues related to comorbid, psychological issues that people are dealing with. One of the things we know, for example, is that family intervention turns out to be very important in terms of helping people who have a substance use disorder, yet the typical treatment program rarely includes families in the treatment. So I think that we need to have a broader understanding of what's needed to support people and to help people to be successful. And I think we need to look at the systemic issues that are involved. I'll give you one example of that. one of the major challenges for our treatment systems is the workforce. We have a workforce in the substance use field where you have people who often don't have the level of training that they
住房。还有人们正在处理的共病心理问题相关的问题。例如，我们所知道的事情之一是，家庭干预对于帮助患有物质使用障碍的人非常重要，然而典型的治疗项目却很少将家庭纳入治疗中。因此，我认为我们需要对支持和帮助人们取得成功所需的东西有更广泛的理解。并且我认为我们需要审视其中涉及的系统性问题。我举一个例子。我们治疗系统面临的主要挑战之一是劳动力。我们在物质使用领域的劳动力往往缺乏他们
need for the complexity of the conditions that they're treating. You have issues of selection and retention of workers. If you go to many treatment programs today and you go to those same programs three years from now, sometimes you'll see as much as a third of the staff have turned over. So if we're trying to attack a major crisis like this, that is one of those issues that we need to address. And so I think one of the things that APA is doing is really trying to reframe how we're thinking about this issue. So we're not only focused on the contributions that we can make as psychologists in terms of treatment, but some of the other areas outside of treatment, and then some of the policy areas like workforce and other policies that are important to address
在应对他们所治疗的复杂病情时所需的培训水平。存在员工的选择和留任问题。如果你今天去许多治疗项目，三年后再去同样的项目，有时你会发现有多达三分之一的员工已经离职。因此，如果我们试图攻击这样一场重大危机，这是我们需要解决的问题之一。因此，我认为APA正在做的事情之一，确实是在重新构想我们如何看待这个问题。所以我们不仅关注作为心理学家在治疗方面可以做出的贡献，还关注治疗之外的一些其他领域，以及一些政策领域，比如劳动力和其他对于解决和
and treating this condition. So you brought up a lot of great points that I want to touch on throughout the rest of the podcast. And just one thing I wanted to clarify, is when you're saying comorbid, you mean people who have an addiction and also who might have depression or anxiety and other mental health condition, correct?
治疗这种病症很重要的政策。所以您提出了很多很好的观点，我希望在接下来的播客中继续探讨。我只想澄清一件事，当您说共病时，您的意思是那些既有成瘾问题，又可能患有抑郁症、焦虑症或其他心理健康状况的人，对吗？
That's correct. And often these issues are present with people. Sometimes they precede the person's addiction to an opioid, and sometimes they come as a result of having an addiction. addiction. The important point is that if we don't treat it, at the same time we're treating the opioid problem, often people are not successful. And we know that medication is a standard and proven way to treat opioid use disorder, but behavioral interventions can also go a long way to improving treatment outcomes. Can you explain why it's critical to treat the person as a whole?
没错。而且这些问题通常会伴随人们出现。有时它们发生在使用阿片类药物成瘾之前，有时它们是成瘾的结果。重要的一点是，如果我们不加以治疗，在治疗阿片类药物问题的同时进行治疗，通常人们不会成功。我们知道药物是治疗阿片类药物使用障碍的标准且经过验证的方法，但行为干预也能对改善治疗效果大有帮助。您能解释一下为什么将人作为一个整体来治疗至关重要吗？
Well, it's because the addiction affects the whole person and if we're going to be successful with people in treating their addiction, it's important to treat the whole person. I gave the example of family intervention a little while ago, extremely important. And if you think about it like this, a person has a substance use disorder. Over time, what happens is family systems begin to accommodate that person's addiction. So even though the family may not want the person to be addicted, when the person begins to engage in recovery and to change, it really throws the family system out of whack. And so families can unwittingly undermine the recovery of a person if you're not also working with the family. So simply treating the person's substance use condition without thinking about the family system and also treating the family system so that the family system can be. supportive can often get in the way of people being successful. So that's one example of why
嗯，这是因为成瘾会影响整个人，如果我们要在治疗人们的成瘾方面取得成功，将整个人作为一个整体来治疗是很重要的。我刚才举了家庭干预的例子，这极其重要。如果你这样想，一个人患有物质使用障碍。随着时间的推移，发生的情况是家庭系统开始适应那个人的成瘾。因此，尽管家庭可能不希望这个人成瘾，但当这个人开始参与康复和改变时，它确实会使家庭系统彻底失衡。因此，如果你不同时与家庭合作，家庭可能会无意中破坏一个人的康复。因此，仅仅治疗个人的物质使用状况，而不考虑家庭系统，也不对家庭系统进行治疗以使其能够提供支持，往往会阻碍人们取得成功。所以这是一个例子，说明为什么
we have to have a more comprehensive view of the condition and a more comprehensive set of strategies that we're employing to work with people. I'm sure friends come into the mix too. I mean, if someone who has an opioid use disorder is spending a lot of time with friends with the same issues, changing that and finding new friends is probably another big challenge as well. It is. It's a very good point. And one of the things we know is that social support is a really major resource and for people who are trying to get and engage in recovery. One of the most powerful things that I saw in my career prior to coming to APA is just the power of peer support and people who are walking with people who are going through the recovery. process. That's probably one of the most powerful things that I've seen, even many times more powerful than the treatments that we have available is having that person who's gone through this journey or is going through this journey with you to help you. And so I think that peer
我们必须对病情有更全面的看法，并采用更全面的策略来与人们合作。我相信朋友也会参与其中。我的意思是，如果一个有阿片类药物使用障碍的人花很多时间与有同样问题的朋友在一起，改变这种状况并寻找新朋友可能也是另一个巨大的挑战。确实如此。这是一个很好的观点。我们知道的一点是，对于那些试图进入并参与康复的人来说，社会支持是一个非常主要的资源。在我来到APA之前，我在职业生涯中看到的最强大的事情之一就是同伴支持的力量，以及那些陪伴正在经历康复过程的人同行的人的力量。这可能是我见过的最强大的事情之一，甚至比我们手头的治疗方法还要强大很多倍，那就是有这样一个曾经经历过这段旅程或正与你一同经历这段旅程的人来帮助你。因此，我认为同伴
support, which is something that most mental health and substitute systems are really focusing on these days is really important. And I think as a policy issue, we really need to support and fund those kinds of efforts. So I want to talk about more of your previous roles. So before you came to APA two years ago, you were Commissioner of Philadelphia's Department of Behavioral Health and Intellectual Disability Service, a health care agency that's the behavioral and intellectual disability safety net
支持，这是大多数心理健康和物质使用系统目前真正关注的事情，确实非常重要。而且我认为作为一项政策问题，我们真的需要支持和资助这类努力。我想更多地谈谈您以前的角色。因此，在两年前来到APA之前，你是费城行为健康和智力残疾服务局的专员，这是一个为150万费城人提供行为和智力残疾安全网的医疗保健机构。你在那里时，调整了该机构的治疗理念和
for 1.5 million Philadelphians. While you were there, you realign the agency's treatment philosophy and services to improve health outcomes. Can you explain more about the work you did there? Well, the work we did was essentially taking some of the things that I've talked about here this morning and really trying to extrapolate them to an entire system. And so one of the major thrusts of our work was to reframe how we thought about addiction and really moved to what's called a recovery management model. And the best way to describe that is this. addiction is often treated as an acute condition.
服务，以改善健康结果。你能多解释一下你在那里做的工作吗？嗯，我们所做的工作本质上是将我今天上午在这里谈到的一些事情，真正尝试将它们推广到整个系统中。因此，我们工作的主要推动力之一是重新构想我们对成瘾的看法，并真正转向所谓的康复管理模型。最好的描述方式是这样的：成瘾通常被当作一种急性病来对待。
So the basic model, the mental model that we have for this is that once a person has a substance use disorder, they come to treatment, we treat them, and then we discharge them, and we assume that the person is well. Well, it turns out that substance use disorders are more like a chronic disease, or more like diabetes, where people may have acute symptoms and acute issues. that you have to deal with, but the real success comes when you create a chronic treatment approach where you're providing support for people ongoing. And so a lot of the work that we did was to build that into our treatment system from a policy standpoint. And that made a big difference. We talked
所以，我们对此的基本模式、心理模式是，一旦一个人有了物质使用障碍，他们来接受治疗，我们治疗他们，然后我们让他们出院，并且我们假设这个人已经康复了。然而事实证明，物质使用障碍更像是一种慢性病，或者更像是糖尿病，人们可能会出现急性症状和你需要处理的急性问题，但真正的成功来自于你创建一个长期的治疗方法，为你持续提供支持。因此，我们的大部分工作是从政策的角度将其构建到我们的治疗系统中。这产生了很大的影响。我们刚才讨论了
about peer support a little while ago. That's a great support and has helped many millions of people to engage in recovery and to sustain their recovery. Well, the things that we could do as a policy body to support that recovery community and providing that kind of support. We also looked at policies, for example, the length of treatment. So one of the things we know from the research is that essentially the longer you stay engaged in treatment, the better your outcomes are going to be. And 90 days is probably the minimum that people need to really engage in long-term recovery, particularly for people who are going into residential treatment programs. But most people know you have 30-day programs and 45-day programs and 20-day programs.
同伴支持。这是一个极好的支持，并帮助了数百万人生参与康复并维持康复。嗯，我们可以作为政策机构做的事情来支持这个康复社区并提供这种支持。我们还研究了政策，例如治疗时间。因此，我们从研究中了解到的事情之一是，本质上你参与治疗的时间越长，你的效果就会越好。90天可能是人们真正参与长期康复所需的最低时间，特别是对于那些进入住院治疗项目的人来说。但大多数人都知道你有30天的项目、45天的项目和20天的项目的项目。
Well, that doesn't really align with what we know from the science. And so part of what we were doing as well is looking at what does the science tell us that will help ensure that people will have a better chance of recovery. And then let's change our policies to align with that science. And what results did you see when you were the Deputy Commissioner of Connecticut's Department of Mental Health and Addiction Services? Well, in Connecticut, we were going through a very similar process. And in fact, Connecticut was the first state in the country under Dr. Thomas Kirk, also a psychologist who very early on decided that we, wanted to, and he wanted to have a system that was built on certain principles and the kind of
嗯，这并不真正符合我们从科学中了解到的东西。因此，我们正在做的一部分工作也是研究科学告诉我们什么将有助于确保人们有更好的康复机会。然后让我们改变我们的政策以符合该科学。当你担任康复局副专员时，你看到了什么结果？在康复局，我们经历了非常类似的过程。事实上，康复局是全国第一个在托马斯·柯克博士（Dr. Thomas Kirk，也是一位心理学家，他很早就决定我们想要，并且他希望有一个建立在某些原则基础上的系统，以及我一直在谈论的那种
principles that I was talking about. And we really went at, went to looking at how we could do this on a systemic and a policy level. And so it's one of the first systems in the country to really try to do that systematically. And, and that's important because the individual clinician can only do so much. So even if you are a clinician who is very committed, understand the science understands the latest treatment approaches, you have to be in a program and in a treatment environment that is going to support those kinds of approaches. And so, you know, that policy work is really important. And it's one of the things that I think the federal government could really be more helpful in is trying to create a policy environment that supports what we know from the
原则）领导下这样做的州。我们真正着手研究如何在系统和政策层面上做到这一点。因此，它是全国第一批真正试图系统地做到这一点的系统之一。而且，这很重要，因为单个临床医生能做的事情是有限的。所以，即使你是一个非常坚定的临床医生，理解科学，了解最新的治疗方法，你也必须身处一个能够支持这种方法的项目和治疗环境中。因此，你知道，这种政策工作真的很重要。而且我认为联邦政府可以在这方面提供更多帮助，那就是努力创造一个政策环境，支持我们从
science works and is best practices. So moving on to APA where I think we'll get into some of that policy. Recently, APA is advocated to nearly double the funding for pain and opioid research at the National Institutes of Health. Can you talk about why research funding is so critical to this issue? It's critical because we don't know a lot of things. So there are a lot of things that we do know about addiction. And in fact, one of the things that I would say, and this is something that a famous
科学中了解到有效且属于最佳实践的方法。所以转向APA，我想我们将进入其中一些政策。最近，APA一直倡导将国立卫生研究院（NIH）对疼痛和阿片类药物研究的资助增加近一倍。你能谈谈为什么研究资助对这个问题如此关键吗？这很关键，因为有很多事情我们并不知道。所以有很多关于成瘾的事情是我们知道的。事实上，我要说的一件事，这是该领域一位著名的
historian in the field, William White talks about, is that we know a lot about addiction, we know a lot less about recovery. And so we need to spend more of our resources understanding what are the mechanisms that really lead to successful recovery, what are the approaches that lead to recovery. We need to study people who are successful in their recovery. One of the things we know is that there are many people who are in recovery who engage in recovery or get into recovery not through the professional treatment system. They go to churches, they go to AA meetings, they go to other resources outside of the treatment system. We need to study that and understand that and to be able to pull that into our armamentarian of strategies that we're using to employ. So that's
历史学家威廉·怀特（William White）所谈到的，那就是我们对成瘾了解很多，对康复了解得少得多。因此，我们需要花更多资源去了解真正导致成功康复的机制是什么，导致康复的方法是什么。我们需要研究那些康复成功的人。我们知道的一件事是，有许多处于康复中的人，他们参与康复或进入康复并不是通过专业治疗系统。他们去教堂，去戒酒互助会（AA），去治疗系统之外的其他资源。我们需要研究这一点，理解这一点，并能够将其纳入我们正在采用的策略库中。所以这是
one of the reasons that research is so important. But the other is that there are things that that we know are related to people developing substance use disorders, and we need to understand those various pathways. So for example, we know that some people develop substance use disorders, particularly opioid disorders because of they're trying to manage pain. We need to understand those mechanisms much better. We know that some people self-medicate because they're dealing with psychological issues like trauma.
研究如此重要的原因之一。但另一个原因是有些事情与人们发展成瘾有关，我们需要了解这些不同的途径。例如，我们知道有些人患上物质使用障碍，特别是阿片类药物障碍，是因为他们试图控制疼痛。我们需要更好地了解这些机制。我们知道有些人因为正在处理创伤等心理问题而进行自我用药。
We know that some people may be engaging in their addiction through other mechanisms. And so understanding that, understanding pain's role, understanding how we can intervene earlier is really important and having the research around that is critical for us. Yeah, and those two groups of people you mentioned were explained in the Monitor article, those at-risk groups. How can psychologists help people in those at-risk groups before they develop a substance use disorder. Well, one of the things is to understand who are the people who are at greatest risk
我们知道有些人可能通过其他机制参与成瘾。因此，理解这一点，理解疼痛的作用，理解我们如何能够更早地进行干预真的很重要，围绕这一点进行研究对我们来说至关重要你在《观察》文章中解释了你提到的那两类高危人群。心理学家如何能在高危人群发展成物质使用障碍之前帮助他们？嗯，其中一件事是了解哪些人面临最大的风险
for using or abusing substance use or using opioids. And people, for example, people who catastrophize or people who overestimate the pain that they are actually experiencing, psychologists can assess that. They're actually tools that psychologists can use to assess the people who are more likely to do that. Those people are also people who are more likely. to abuse opioids. And so that kind of assessment, I think, allows us to both on the medical side and on the,
使用或滥用物质或使用阿片类药物。例如，那些灾难化思维的人，或者高估他们实际经历的疼痛的人，心理学家可以对此进行评估。实际上有心理学家可以使用的工具来评估那些更有可能这样做的人。这些人也更有可能是
on the substance use treatment side, design interventions that are tailored to a particular person. And I've heard you say about chronic pain that there's no scientific evidence that opioids are the best treatment. So acute pain, yes, but not chronic pain. So I think that was quite surprising, given that how widely opioids are being prescribed. why do you think they're prescribed so often for chronic pain and what all their non-pharmaceutical interventions can help people? Well, I think the fast answer to that question is there's a profit
滥用阿片类药物的人。因此，我认为这种评估使我们能够在医学方面和物质使用治疗方面，设计出针对特定个人的干预措施。我听你关于慢性疼痛说过，没有科学证据表明阿片类药物是最好的治疗方法。所以急性疼痛可以，但慢性疼痛不行。因此，考虑到阿片类药物被广泛处方的现状，我认为这相当令人惊讶。你认为为什么它们经常被开用于慢性疼痛，还有哪些非药物干预措施可以帮助人们？嗯，对那个问题的快速回答是存在利益动机。
motive. And I think there have been a number of recent reports on how opioids have been promoted for uses that, for which they were not actually designed. And so I don't think we can, I think we have the fact of that into the part of the equation. But beyond that, I think that there are alternatives. One of the things that health psychologists do in particular is to help people to manage pain in ways that help people to manage their pain in ways that don't require them to use the level of opioids or opioids at all. And that's an important strategy. There are other things that people outside psychology do, whether it's yoga or other kinds of strategies that help people to manage their pain without having to rely on medications. And that's going to be important.
而且我认为最近有许多关于阿片类药物如何被推广用于其并未实际设计的用途的报告。所以我不认为我们可以，我认为我们必须将这一事实纳入方程的一部分。但除此之外，我认为还有替代方案。健康心理学家所做的特别事情之一是帮助人们以不需要他们使用大量阿片类药物或根本不用阿片类药物的方式来管理疼痛。这是一个重要的策略。还有心理学之外的人们做的其他事情，无论是瑜伽还是其他有助于人们在不依赖药物的情况下管理疼痛的策略。这将是很重要的。
We have millions of people who are currently addicted to opioids in this country. Many of them are addicted because of their attempts to manage pain. And if we're going to get ahead of this issue, we need to look at a variety of ways of helping people to manage pain without medication or at least using less medication. And AP is also working to implement a new law that will expand treatment. Can you explain more about this law? Well, there's several laws that are designed to help expand treatment. Some of them are expanding services like telehealth.
我们国家目前有数百万对阿片类药物上瘾的人。其中许多人上瘾是因为他们试图控制疼痛。如果我们要在这个问题上取得领先，我们需要寻找各种方法来帮助人们在没有药物或至少使用较少药物的情况下控制疼痛。APA还在努力实施一项将扩大治疗的新法律。你能更多地解释一下这项法律吗？嗯，有几项法律旨在帮助扩大治疗。其中一些正在扩大远程医疗等服务。
They're making it easier to do those kinds of services. We know in particularly in rural communities, there are often a lack of professional. to help people, and we want to make sure that there are professionals that can help, and people can have access to those folks. So much of the work that we're doing is really trying to make sure that those kind of services are available. We're also very interested in policies that support things like housing. We know that housing is a very important component to a person's resources that they need for recovery.
它们让提供这些服务变得更容易。我们知道，特别是在农村社区，往往缺乏专业人员来帮助人们，我们希望确保有专业人员可以提供帮助，并且人们可以获得这些专业人员的帮助。我们正在做的很多工作确实是试图确保这些服务是可用的。我们也非常对支持住房等政策感兴趣。我们知道住房是个人康复所需资源的一个非常重要的组成部分。
And it's something that is often not available to people yet really critical. And so our advocacy is around those things that we know from the research or from the science are critical to supporting people. And I definitely want to touch on the housing first idea, which it means that people with substance use disorders or those in recovery are given a safe place to live through subsidies. And a few were noted in the Monitor article that are being led by psychologists. They were the Heart Center in Seattle and Elm City communities in New Haven, Connecticut. Why do you think psychologists are good choice to lead these programs?
而这往往是人们无法获得却又至关重要的东西。因此，我们的倡导围绕着那些我们从研究或科学中知道对支持人们至关重要的东西。我绝对想谈谈“住房优先”的理念，这意味着患有物质使用障碍或正在康复的人通过补贴获得一个安全的居住地。文章中提到了一些由心理学家领导的项目，它们是西雅图的心脏中心（Heart Center）和康涅狄格州纽黑文的埃尔姆城社区（Elm City communities）。你认为为什么心理学家是领导这些项目的绝佳选择？
Well, I think that one of the skills that psychologist brings is their ability to assess behavior, their ability to design treatment programs or treatment strategies. And one of the things, much of the housing first work is done for people who are homeless. So if a person is living on the streets, they have a substitute disorder, they have a mental health condition traditionally and historically what we would have done is to try to help the person get into recovery first and then go into housing. What the housing first model does is kind of turns that on its head. And it says the first strategy is to get the person stable in housing and then have the services come to the person in supported housing. And that turns out to be a very effective strategy, particularly for people who have serious mental illnesses, but also for people who have certain substance use disorders as well.
嗯，我认为心理学家带来的技能之一是他们评估行为的能力，他们设计治疗方案或治疗策略的能力。其中一件事，大部分“住房优先”工作都是为无家可归的人做的。因此，如果一个人流落街头，他们有物质使用障碍，他们有心理健康状况，传统上和历史上我们会做的是首先试图帮助这个人进入康复状态，然后再去住房。“住房优先”模型所做的是将其颠倒过来。它说第一个策略是让人们在住房中稳定下来，然后将服务带到支持性住房中的人身边。事实证明，这是一种非常有效的策略，特别是对于患有严重精神疾病的人，但也对于患有某些物质使用障碍的人同样有效。
And I think that psychologists can be very helpful in that process because many of the people who have substance use disorders and often comorbid with mental health issues who are homeless is that you really need a good assessment of what's going on with a person and you need to design and tailor the treatment and supports for that particular person. And that's an area where psychologists, I think, are really strong. And I'm sure it's more helpful to have people in a home as opposed to a treatment facility. It might just have a different feel and people might feel more comfortable if they're in a place where they know they'll be staying. Stability is very important.
而且我认为心理学家在这个过程中非常有帮助，因为许多无家可归的患有物质使用障碍且通常伴有心理健康共病的人，你真的需要对这个人身上发生的事情进行良好的评估，你需要为这个人设计和定制治疗和支持。我认为这是心理学家的强项。而且我相信让人住在家里而不是治疗机构里会更有帮助，这可能会有不同的感觉，如果人们在一个他们知道自己会呆下去的地方，他们可能会感到更舒服。稳定性非常重要。
If you just think, if we personalize and think about ourselves, if we don't have a home to go to at the end of the day, it's very destabilizing. And if you're trying to recover from a substance use disorder, it's very, very difficult to do that if you don't have stable housing. And people with opioid use disorder often end up in the criminal justice system. And there are drug courts where judges supervise every aspect of treatment and recovery. And they're being seen as more often as a better alternative. You know, where do psychologists fit into this work? Well, you know, just to understand the role of drug courts, you know, one of the things, one of the misnomer's or one of the myths in the field is that people
如果你想想，如果我们个性化地考虑我们自己，如果我们在一天结束时没有一个可以回家的家，那是极其不稳定的。如果你试图从物质使用障碍中恢复过来，如果你没有稳定的住房，那是极其困难的。患有阿片类药物使用障碍的人经常最终进入刑事司法系统。有药物法院，法官监督治疗和康复的各个方面。它们正越来越被视为更好的替代方案。你知道，心理学家如何融入这项工作？嗯，你知道，只是为了理解药物法院的作用，你知道，该领域的一个误区或神话是人们
have to want to engage in recovery. That's just not true. And the reason that we know that that's not true is from the research that shows that whether people come into treatment voluntarily or involuntarily, the treatment outcomes are roughly the same. And so drug courts turn out to be a really important part of our overall strategy because what they do is that they really force some people who are not ready to engage in treatment. They are literally mandated to go to treatment or they go to jail and most people take treatment over jail. And so what we know is that those programs can be very effective. And I think psychologists can play a number of roles there.
必须希望参与康复。那根本不是真的。我们知道这不是真的原因来自研究，研究表明，无论人们是自愿还是非自愿进入治疗，治疗结果大致相同。因此，药物法院最终成为我们总体策略中非常重要的一部分，因为它们所做的是强迫一些尚未准备好参与治疗的人。他们被字面意义上强制去接受治疗，否则就要去监狱，而大多数人会选择治疗而不是监狱。因此，我们知道这些项目非常有效。我认为心理学家可以在其中扮演多种角色。
Assessment as we talked about earlier is a really important role. Also understanding the the, the co-modelial. morbid mental health issues. And I think that's really important. Many of the people who end up in court often have a very long history of substance use. And they have many complicated issues around their substance use. And I think to the degree that we can get a better handle on what those issues are and target our interventions, we're going to have a much better shot at those people are going to have a much better shot at long-term recovery. And I think that that's a really important role that psychologists can play in that setting.
正如我们之前所讨论的，评估是一个非常重要的角色。还有理解共病心理健康问题。我认为这非常重要。许多最终进入法庭的人通常有很长的物质使用史。他们围绕物质使用有很多复杂的问题。我认为，只要我们能更好地掌握这些问题是什么并针对性地进行干预，我们就会有更好的机会，那些人将有更好的机会实现长期康复。我认为这是心理学家在该环境中可以发挥的非常重要的作用。
And there's definitely a lot of stigma around people who have opioid use disorder. I probably would say it's fairly common. Do you think it stops people from seeking help and does it hinder recovery? I think it really prevents people from getting the help that they need. I think it plays out in lots of different ways. I think one is that it plays out in that people don't reach out for the help that need because they're embarrassed, they're ashamed. And but it also affects the policies that we have.
对患有阿片类药物使用障碍的人肯定存在很多污名化。我可能会说这相当普遍。你认为它是否阻止了人们寻求帮助，是否阻碍了康复？我认为它确实阻止了人们获得他们需要的帮助。我认为它在许多不同的方面发挥作用。我认为其中一个方面是，人们不会伸出援手寻求所需的帮助，因为他们感到尴尬、羞耻。但这也会影响我们拥有的政策。
I think, you know, where we started this interview is talking about is the country doing enough? Well, I think one of the reasons that we're not doing enough is because of the stigma associated with substance use disorders. If this were, you know, we had 130 people dying every day from practically any other health condition, I think this country would be really focused on. addressing that and the fact that we're not, I think it has a, that stigma has a lot to do with the fact that we're not. So I think it's something that we have to deal with in my previous work in both Connecticut and in Philadelphia, we spent a good bit of time thinking about the
我想，你知道我们这次采访开始的地方是在谈论这个国家做得够不够？嗯，我认为我们做得不够的原因之一是与物质使用障碍相关的污名化。如果这是一项，你知道的，我们每天有130人死于几乎任何其他健康状况，我认为这个国家会真正专注于解决这个问题，而事实上我们没有，我认为污名化与我们没有这样做有很大关系。所以我认为这是我们必须处理的事情，在我以前在康涅狄格州和费城的工作中，我们花了很多时间思考
issue of stigma and how to address that. One of the things that happens in, from a policy standpoint, is that policymakers are often so focused on service delivery, they're not thinking about the issue of stigma. And they're certainly not using resources to address that issue. But one of the things I would say quite often is that it doesn't matter if we have the best treatment programs in the country and they're the most effective
污名化的问题以及如何解决这个问题。从政策的角度来看发生的事情之一是，政策制定者往往过于关注服务交付，而没有考虑污名化的问题。他们当然也没有使用资源来解决这个问题。但我经常说的一件事是，如果我们拥有全国最好的治疗项目且它们最有效，但这并不重要
if people don't come to them. And so we have to, as we're building capacity, we also have to think about how do we help help the, how do we help reduce the stigma so that people will actually reach out for help, that family members and coworkers will know how to help support people and to get them connected to services. And that has to be a part of our overall strategy. So it's something that I think APA can be very involved in. And it's something that I'm really looking forward to us playing a more, a greater leadership role in. Do you think the stigma is lessening a little bit because a lot of
如果人们不来。因此，在我们建设能力的同时，我们也必须考虑如何帮助减少污名化，以便人们真正寻求帮助，让家庭成员和同事知道如何支持人们并让他们与服务建立联系。这必须是我们总体策略的一部分。因此，我认为APA可以深入参与其中。我真的期待我们在其中发挥更大、更具领导力的作用。你认为污名化正在减少一点吗，因为很多
stories I've read in the news feature, you know, people from all walks of life who've been grappling with addiction. It seems like every corner of America has been affected by this crisis. I think stigma is being reduced. One metric that I used in my previous work, you know, we had a recovery walk in Philadelphia that started with 150 people. These are mostly people who are in recovery and sort of like the breast cancer walks. People are coming out. to put a face on recovery. You know, you go to that walk today, it's, you know, it's almost 30,000 people.
我在新闻中读到的故事，你知道，来自各行各业一直在与成瘾作斗争的人。美国似乎每个角落都受到这场危机的打击。我认为污名化正在减少。我在以前的工作中使用的一个指标，你知道，我们在费城举行了一次康复游行，开始时有150人。这些人大多是康复中的人，有点像乳腺癌游行。人们走出来展示康复的面貌。你知道，你今天去参加那个游行，有将近3万人。
And over half of that group, well over half that group, are people who are in recovery. So people are much more willing today to be public about their recovery. You know, one of the things I really like about the recovery movement that's happening around the country now is that, you know, when I came into the field, anonymity was really the way that
其中一半以上的人，远超一半的人，都是处于康复中的人。因此，今天的人们更愿意公开他们的康复情况。你知道，我真的很喜欢现在全国各地正在发生的康复运动的一点是，当我进入这个领域时，匿名真的是
It was really the way people dealt with their recovery. And so, you know, people wouldn't disclose. Today, I love it when I go to an event and someone says, you know, hi, I'm Bob. I've been in long-term recovery for 20 years. And that means I haven't taken a drink or a drug in the last 20 years. And they explain what that means. And here's Bob, who's in a suit, who's this successful business executive or lawyer or whoever he is. is, and he's being very public about that.
人们处理康复的真正方式。所以，你知道，人们不会公开。今天，我真的很喜欢当我参加一个活动时，有人说，嗨，我是鲍勃。我已经长期康复20年了。这意味着我在过去20年里没有喝过酒或吸过毒。他们解释这意味着什么。这里是穿着西装的鲍勃，一个成功的商业高管或律师或无论他是谁，他非常公开地谈论这一点。
The public sees people who are addicted all the time. They see how that plays out. What they don't see are the people around them who are in recovery, who've been successful. And so the more people talk about that, the more, I believe, it reduces stigma. And I hope, you know, 10 years from now we'll be having a different conversation about this, that we've actually moved the Dow
公众一直在看到成瘾的人。他们看到那是如何发展的。他们没有看到他们身边那些正在康复、已经成功的人。因此，人们谈论得越多，我相信，它就越能减少污名化。我希望，你知道，10年后的我们会对此进行不同的对话，我们已经取得了很大进展
to such a degree that we have policies and we have people who are educated in our communities who can really help those of us who are struggling with addiction. I think words can matter a lot in terms of how we describe people with opioid use disorder. You know, for instance, instead of calling someone a drug addict, we would say a person living with addiction or a person with substance use disorder. Do you think that helps to lessen the stigmas in terms of like the language we use? I think it's very important. And I hope that every single person listening today and to this podcast will make a commitment
以至于我们有政策，我们的社区里有受过教育的人，他们真的可以帮助我们当中那些正在与成瘾作斗争的人。我认为在如何描述患有阿片类药物使用障碍的人方面，词语可以产生很大的影响。你知道，例如，与其称呼某人为吸毒者，我们会说与成瘾共存的人或患有物质使用障碍的人。你认为这有助于从我们使用的语言方面减少污名化吗？我认为这非常重要。我希望今天听这个播客的每个人都能做出承诺
not to use the word addict. I think it is very stigmatizing. It sounds like a condition that people can't get over. And I understand why, you know, particularly many of the self-help groups that people use that because what they were essentially saying is, look, once you have an addiction, you have that, you know, throughout your life and you have to manage that. I get that, but using that terminology, I think, stigmatizes people. That's why I really like people who talk about, you know, I'm Bob, I'm a person in long-term recovery. Same, you know, same condition, but I think that gives a very,
不使用“瘾君子”这个词。我认为这非常有污名化。听起来像是一种人们无法克服的病症。我理解为什么，你知道，特别是人们使用的许多自助小组使用那个，因为他们本质上在说的是，看，一旦你有了成瘾，你就会在你的生命中拥有它，你必须控制它。我明白，但使用这种术语，我认为会污名化人们。这就是为什么我真的很喜欢那些谈论的人，你知道，我是鲍勃，我是一个处于长期康复中的人。同样的，你知道，同样的状况，但我认为这给了公众
gives a public a very different understanding of what this is about in terms of being in recovery. And in terms of prevention, I know we've touched on this a little bit throughout the podcast, but can you explain a little more where psychologists fit into that? So is that addressing some of these other mental health issues before they turn into a substance use disorder? Yeah, I think it's all of that. I think that people develop addictions different ways through different pathways. And I think psychologists who can help identify those pathways, are really important to our overall set of strategies.
对处于康复状态的含义有一个非常不同的理解。在预防方面，我知道我们在整个播客中多多少少都谈到过这一点，你能多解释一下心理学家在其中的切入点吗？所以这是在这些其他心理健康问题转化为物质使用障碍之前解决它们吗？是的，我认为就是所有这些。我认为人们通过不同的途径以不同的方式发展成瘾。我认为能够帮助识别这些途径的心理学家，对我们的整个策略集非常重要。
So understanding pain and being able to prevent people from, or at least identifying that people were at highest risk is actually a really good strategy for reducing the likelihood that someone is going to become addicted to pain medication. Addressing trauma, trauma actually turns out to be an issue that we find to a very high degree in people who have substance use conditions. And to the degree that we are identifying that early on and using evidence-based treatment approaches that have been developed by psychologists,
因此，了解疼痛并能够阻止人们，或者至少识别出处于最高风险的人，实际上是降低某人对止痛药上瘾可能性的一个非常好的策略。解决创伤，创伤实际上被证明是在患有物质使用条件的人中发现高度存在的一个问题。并且在我们早期识别这一点并使用由心理学家开发的循证治疗方法的程度上，
that is an important strategy in reducing the likelihood that people will self-medicate to manage their trauma. I think that there are other ways that psychologists can be very helpful in terms of early identification. You know, I have some colleagues who are health psychologists and they work with people who are suffering from pain and often those individuals have not only pain, but they have depression, they have anxiety, they have a number of conditions. And I think if we can get in there earlier and treat the whole person, treat all of those
这是减少人们为了管理创伤而进行自我用药可能性的一个重要策略。我认为心理学家在早期识别方面还可以通过其他方式提供很大帮助。你知道，我有一些同事是健康心理学家，他们与遭受疼痛的人合作，通常这些人不仅有疼痛，他们还有抑郁症、焦虑症，他们有许多状况。我认为如果我们能够更早地介入并治疗整个人，治疗所有这些
conditions and not treat them as sort of these independent separate issues, that we're going to have a much better chance of helping people and preventing them from developing long. term substance use disorders. And as we've discussed, you've had a lot of experience working with state and city governments. What do you think psychologists can do at both the local level and the state level? On the one hand, I think it's important for psychologists to be actively engaged in direct services, and that's what we're trained to do, many of us who are clinically trained to do that work. but I also think it's really important for psychologists to be much more involved in administration and in
状况，而不是把它们当作某种独立分开的问题，我们就会有更大的机会去帮助人们，并防止他们发展成长期的物质使用障碍。正如我们所讨论的，你在与州和市政府合作方面有很多经验。你认为心理学家在地方层面和州层面可以做些什么？一方面，我认为心理学家积极参与直接服务是很重要的，这是我们受过培训去做的事情，我们当中许多接受过临床培训的人都在做那项工作。但我也认为，对于心理学家来说，更多地参与行政管理和
policy making. And the reason is that psychologists bring a unique perspective to that work. Psychologists are trained as both scientists and as clinicians. And I can tell you from my work in working in public policy, you have to, having a scientific background and foundation in your work is really important. When you start to set policies for tens of thousands of people, you don't want to do that by anecdote. And often you see too many policies that are based on a limited set of experiences, but that's the experiences that the policymaker has been exposed to. You know, psychologist's training and having experience in looking at data and using data and using research are really important in developing policies that are much more grounded and much more grounded in research,
制定政策真的非常重要。原因在于心理学家为这项工作带来了独特的视角。心理学家既接受过科学家的培训，也接受过临床医生的培训。我可以根据我在公共政策领域工作的经验告诉你，你必须、在工作中拥有科学背景和基础是非常重要的。当你开始为成千上万的人制定政策时，你可不想凭轶事来做这件事。通常你会看到太多政策都是基于一组有限的经验，而那只是政策制定者接触过的经验。你知道，心理学家的培训以及在查看数据、使用数据和利用研究方面的经验，对于制定更扎实且更扎根于研究的政策来说非常重要，
but also policies that will have the greatest impact and will have reached the most people, but also be the policies that are having the most impact in terms of what we're trying to accomplish. So I think that that training and that perspective is a very important aspect. You know, other disciplines have other perspectives. and skills that they bring. And I think that that's important. But I do think that there is a unique role for people who are trained as both scientists and practitioners and being able to bridge the clinical policies with the research and the science.
同时也能够产生最大影响、惠及最多人群的政策，并且在我们要完成的目标方面产生最大影响。所以我认为这种培训和视角是一个非常重要的方面。你知道，其他学科也有他们带来的其他视角和技能。我认为这也很重要。但我确实认为，对于那些既受过科学家培训又受过实践者培训的人来说，有一个独特的作用，那就是能够将临床政策与研究和科学连接起来。
And as we discussed some of the programs you've been involved with in Philadelphia and Connecticut that are recovery first models and they also involve the full family and friends into the picture, do you think those can be serve as models for addressing the opioid crisis? in other states and cities, or have they been already? They have been, and there are more and more people, not only in the United States, but literally around the world. I've spoken in Australia, New Zealand, and Sweden, and lots of different places around the world.
正如我们所讨论的，你参与过的一些在费城和康涅狄格州的项目，它们是以恢复为先的模型，并且还将完整的家庭和朋友纳入其中，你认为这些可以作为应对其他州和城市的阿片类药物危机的模型吗，或者它们已经发挥了这种作用？是的，而且越来越多的人，不仅在美国，而且实际上在世界各地都在这样做。我在澳大利亚、新西兰、瑞典以及世界各地许多不同的地方做过演讲。
And I think we all are dealing with the same issues. We are dealing, you know, the way substance use disorders play out in Philadelphia or Washington, D.C. or Stockholm, pretty much the same. And we know some things from the research and from our experience about what are effective policies. And so I think it's really important for us to have ways of sharing our lessons earned. I think it's one of the roles that APA can play, which is as a convener of people from different places, from different disciplines coming together, sharing what we've learned that has worked. and then trying to replicate that in places around the country. Bringing this back to the federal level, APAs also provided expert input for the President's
而且我认为我们都在处理相同的问题。我们在处理，你知道，物质使用障碍在费城、华盛顿特区或斯德哥尔摩的表现方式几乎是一样的。我们从研究和经验中了解哪些是有效的政策。因此，我认为对我们来说，拥有分享我们吸取到的经验教训的方法真的很重要。我认为这是美国心理学会（APA）可以发挥的作用之一，即作为一个来自不同地方、不同学科的人们的召集人，大家聚在一起，分享我们学到的行之有效的方法，然后试图在全国各地复制它。把话题拉回联邦层面，APA还为总统的
Commission on Combating Drug Addiction in the Opioid Crisis. Can you talk about what APA said in that? Well, I think the one thing that we said that was really important was that we have to take a comprehensive approach to this issue. We need to advance non-pharmacological interventions for pain. we need to make sure that we are funding these kinds of services adequately. And we need to really, one of the things that we really need to do is to make sure that we're addressing issues like workforce and other kinds of policies that are important in terms of creating a comprehensive system. And you talked about what you hope to see in 10 years from now as terms of how we see people who are having substance use disorders.
打击药物成瘾和阿片类药物危机委员会提供了专家意见。你能谈谈APA在其中说了什么吗？嗯，我认为我们说的一件非常重要的事情是，我们必须对这个问题采取综合的方法。我们需要推进针对疼痛的非药物干预措施，我们需要确保充分资助这些类型的服务。我们需要真正做的其中一件事是，确保我们正在解决劳动力等问题以及其他在建立综合系统方面很重要的政策。你谈到了你希望在从现在开始的10年后，在看待有物质使用障碍的人方面看到什么情况。
What is your hope in the next year or five years or ten years in terms of what we're seeing around the country with the opioid epidemic? Well, I would hope that we are at a place in this country where the stigma is much less and that people are willing to engage in treatment. I would hope that there were more people who were talking about their journey of recovery. I would hope that we would have policymakers that were more informed. You know, those who are in the executive branch and who are the experts to lead federal agencies and state agencies are one thing, and they have a certain level of understanding. But legislators make a lot of policies. They determine funding levels.
你对未来一年、五年或十年里我们在全国范围内看到的阿片类药物流行情况有什么期望？嗯，我希望我们国家的耻辱感能大大减轻，人们愿意参与治疗。我希望有更多的人谈论他们的康复历程。我希望我们能有更多开明的政策制定者。你知道，那些在行政部门中担任联邦机构和州机构专家的领导是一回事，他们具有一定水平的理解力。但立法者制定了大量的政策。他们决定资助水平。
They make the laws. And we need to make sure that those folks have the knowledge and understanding of what it takes for a good comprehensive system. And I would hope that over the next 10 years, we, APA, could be very involved in helping to educate those legislators and policymakers so that they can make better decisions about how we address these issues. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Evans. It's been a really thought-provoking discussion about the opioid epidemic and the role of psychology. Thank you. I've enjoyed it. If you're a psychologist and interested in learning more about how you can get involved in helping address the opioid epidemic, the Monitor's Special Report has a lot of great resources. Be sure to also check out our episode from November 2018 called Using Psychology for Pain Relief and Opioid Reduction with guest Dr. Beth Darnall of Stanford University. It focused on the millions of Americans using opioids to manage chronic pain and how psychology and mindfulness can treat them and help people with chronic pain live better lives.
他们制定法律。我们需要确保这些人具备了解建立一个良好的综合系统所需的知识和理解力。我希望在未来10年里，我们APA能够非常深入地参与帮助教育这些立法者和政策制定者，以便他们能够就我们如何解决这些问题做出更好的决定。非常感谢你加入我们的节目，埃文斯博士。这是一场关于阿片类药物流行病和心理学作用的真正引人深思的讨论。谢谢你。我很喜欢。如果你是一名心理学家，并有兴趣了解更多关于如何参与帮助解决阿片类药物危机的信息，《监测》特刊有很多极好的资源。请务必查看我们2018年11月的那期节目，名为《利用心理学缓解疼痛和减少阿片类药物》，嘉宾是斯坦福大学的贝丝·达纳尔博士。它重点关注了数百万使用阿片类药物来控制慢性疼痛的美国人，以及心理学和正念如何能够治疗他们并帮助慢性疼痛患者过上更好的生活。
You can find that episode on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's also posted on Speaking of Psychology.org. Before we go, just a reminder to let you know we want to hear from you. You can email me your comments and ideas to K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-R. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network,
你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到那一期节目。它也发布在Speaking of Psychology.org上。在我们离开之前，提醒大家一声，我们希望听到您的声音。你可以把你的评论和想法发电子邮件给我，地址是K-Luna@apa.org。也就是K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-R。另外，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。我们将非常感激。《心理学之声》是APA播客网络的一部分，
which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其中包括其他优秀的播客，例如关于新心理学研究的APA期刊对话（APA Journal's Dialogue）以及关于心理学实践的进展记录（Progress Notes）。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 来收听更多节目。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢娜（Caitlin Luna）。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。